monsieur hublot bonjour Le globet de
merde rapportait ce matin que le projet
de terminal de Contrecoeur augmente de
50% de l'estimation à un milliard 400
millions de dollars est-ce que vous êtes
en mesure de confirmer cette information
ce chiffre vient pas de nous
ce qui a fait les manchettes cette
dernière temps c'est les discussions
avec les paliers de gouvernement parce
qu'on subit effectivement une inflation
importante par rapport à notre dernier
estimé de coup qui avait été fait en
2019 donc ce chiffre-là ne manne pas de
nous et c'est encore confidentiel mais
c'est une inflation qui est importante
depuis quelques années on estimait 950
millions le projet a en 2019 vous êtes
toujours sur cette estimation de 950
millions mais c'est 950 c'est terne 2019
et la covid a vraiment changé les
repères de l'industrie de la
construction et donc c'est l'inflation
entre le 950 et le chiffre actuel c'est
la raison pour laquelle on interpelle on
a interpellé Québec et Ottawa pour nous
aider à
joindre les deux bouffes le 1 milliard
400 millions vous le confirmez pas je
confirme pas c'est un chiffre qui de
quelqu'un d'autre cela dit c'est une
inflation importante mais comme on est
en négociation présentement avec des
consortium privés j'irai pas parler d'un
chiffre précis parce que c'est dans la
relation contractuelle qu'on est en
train finaliser que notre partenaire
est-ce que vous êtes en mesure de
confirmer que vous demandez à Ottawa
d'injecter 150 millions de dollars
supplémentaires dans le projet on a
demandé l'aide de Québec et d'Ottawa
dans le dernier budget à Québec on a eu
75 millions d'aides additionnels donc
135 millions du gouvernement du Québec
et en même temps on était en discussion
avec le gouvernement Ottawa et j'ai eu
une conversation avec le ministre cette
semaine qui m'a confirmé qu'il
travaillait à une solution qu'il a
besoin encore d'un peu de temps mais que
cette année infrastructure stratégique
qu'ils allaient être là et je suis pas
capable de vous confirmer l'ampleur et
le calendrier précis mais suite à cette
conversation là on est très confiant
d'arriver très prochainement on me dit
que quelques semaines c'est une question
quelques semaines est-ce que quelque
chose qui bloque dans les négociations
et que le gouvernement fédéral
commenter ça je vous dirais que on a
laissé savoir à tout le monde que
c'était urgent parce que les
négociations sur ce projet-là sont à la
fin on arrive vraiment à la ligne
d'arrivée et ça fait plusieurs mois
qu'on est en discussion avec les
palettes gouvernement qui se passe si ça
marche pas ou qu'est-ce qui est en jeu
qu'est-ce qui est en péril 2027 d'avoir
le terminal en 2020
il faut que tout arrive en même temps
les permis le financement
l'intérêt du public et tout est bien
ficelé présentement donc on peut pas
changer le calendrier je veux pas qu'on
change l'ampleur du projet on est
vraiment la ligne d'arrivée et c'est une
infrastructure stratégique et c'est ce
que ministre nous dit pour le Québec
pour l'Ontario et pour le Canada et on a
eu des crises logistiques il y a pas
meilleur temps de réaliser contre coeur
mais on a l'impression que c'est c'est
complexe et que ça fait des années qu'on
parle de Contrecoeur là on arrive
peut-être à quelque chose mais il y a
peut-être du retard puis en même temps
on voit le port de Vancouver les plans
d'un terminal de 3 milliards 500
millions qui ont été approuvés par le
gouvernement on a l'impression que ça
avance plus vite du côté de Vancouver
vous savez contrecar ça fait 30 ans
c'est en développement et c'est cette
année on va prendre la décision finale
d'investissement parce que c'est long
pour bien faire les choses là le montage
est prêt les permis dernier permis vont
être obtenu dans les dans les prochains
mois la nécessité est démontrée et on
est très confiant que le calendrier va
être respecté et cette année on lance le
projet pour demain mais pourquoi c'est
déjà approuvé avant couvert c'est pas
déjà approuvé en fait ils ont une
déclaration positive du ministre de
l'environnement comme nous avons eu une
déclaration positive de l'environnement
il y a maintenant plus de deux ans et
ensuite il y a encore plusieurs étapes
environnementales qu'il faut mettre en
place donc ils ont encore plusieurs
étapes à franchir nous on est très près
de la ligne d'arrivée et je commencerai
pas davantage leur réalité vous n'êtes
pas en concurrence avec absolument pas
on est en courant développé de
l'activité portuaire partout au Canada
c'est le nerf de la compétitivité du
Canada l'honneur de la guerre c'est la
fluidité portuaire pour les prochaines
années et le Canada
a pas suffisamment investi dans ces
infrastructures critiques au cours des
dernières décennies c'est pour ça que
Halifax le fait St John le fait Montréal
Québec et Vancouver et ça risque de ne
pas être assez encore donc il faut
vraiment mettre en place les bonnes
infrastructures comme vous savez la
grève des fonctionnaires on est rendu au
jour 9 en début de semaine on a reçu le
vice-président exécutif régional de
l'Alliance de la fonction publique qui
nous disait ceci
est-ce que vous allez bloquer des ports
et des aéroports allez-vous aller plus
loin là-dessus définitivement si on n'a
pas d'entente dans les prochaines heures
des prochaines journées on va augmenter
nos moyens de pression absolument
et donc est-ce que vous craignez que les
fonctionnaires en viennent à bloquer le
port de Montréal
s'il pense au port c'est parce que c'est
critique c'est la raison pour laquelle
il pense à ce blocage je vous dirais
simplement que à deux reprises cette
semaine il y a eu des interventions des
travailleurs prennent nos
infrastructures présence importante même
mais ça a été très civilisé il y a pas
eu d'impact opérationnel malgré la
présence c'était à la fois sécuritaire
courtois et on a respecté les
manifestants mais les opérations ont pas
été affectées mais allez-vous jusqu'à
espérer qu'il y a une loi spéciale pour
pas en arriver à ce qu'on bloque le port
de Montréal ça monsieur Fillon c'est
plus grand que moi je me mêlerai pas des
négociations contractuelles qui me
regardent pas ok réunion annuelle du
port de Montréal de l'Administration
portuaire aujourd'hui l'année 2022 a été
une bonne année est-ce que 2023 années
possible de récession sera plus
difficile 22 ça a été l'année de la
reprise donc on est cap de retour aussi
performant qu'il y a quelques années 23
commence un peu plus au ralenti donc on
a des volumes notamment des volumes dans
conteneurs qui sont un peu plus faibles
par rapport au premier trimestre hier je
regardais les résultats financiers d'un
compagnie ferroviaire qui constatait la
même chose donc il y a un ralentissement
économique que nous sentons dans le
premier trimestre c'est indéniable il y
a une compagnie ferroviaire qui
s'appelle le Canadien National qui
disait selon nos estimations avec les
chargements en ce moment nous sommes
déjà dans une récession présentement au
Canada est-ce que vous faites le même
constat le mot récession il m'appartient
pas c'est une question économique mais
nous vivons un ralentissement
opérationnel et commercial au port et
comme généralement on est un indicateur
prédictif on peut se douter quand au
Québec et en Ontario il y a un
ralentissement économique quand même
assez important dernier dernier sujet
que je vais aborder avec vous ce sont
bien sûr les cyber-attaques deux
cyber-attaques récemment au port de
Montréal est-ce que l'intégrité
numérique du port de Montréal est à
risque en ce moment deux attaques
importantes plusieurs parts Canadiens
ont été attaqués en même temps
en aucun temps les informations ont été
mis en danger
du système ont bien réagi nos
protections ont bien réagi les équipes
ont bien réagi et il y a une
concertation instantanée entre les ports
mais aussi avec certaines autres
infrastructures importantes au Québec
par exemple Hydro-Québec et autres et
s'il y a une chose que l'on vient
d'apprendre c'est que toutes les
infrastructures Québec québécois les
infrastructures critiques au Québec et
au Canada doivent se concerter de façon
beaucoup plus régulière pour mettre en
place des bonnes mesures des bonnes
pratiques des bonnes mesures de sécurité
on n'est pas en concurrence sur ces
questions là et moi je vais interpeler
mes collègues pour qu'on en fasse
davantage ensemble pour se prémunir de
ces attaques là
monsieur d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
toujours pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI